a lot of things you can do with a
hatchet and a Nazi
[Music]
pay attention
above all else Wolfenstein - the new
Colossus takes a very hard stance on the
righteousness of killing Nazis it never
falters not once asking whether violent
resistance is the wrong way to fight
back against oppression and the game is
stronger for it the series
tongue-in-cheek attitude provides a
respite from both the horrors of the
Reich in the frustration of throwing
yourself against its all-powerful war
machine and despite some heavy-handed
moments that feel like missteps in its
message it's satisfying Nazi killing
action bolsters it's completely bonkers
storyline in a way that only Wolfenstein
can achieve the new classes picks up
right after the events of the new order
and unsurprisingly our hero blaskowitz
is in bad shape following the explosion
during the fight with deaths head BJ's
insights are falling out and the crew of
the kreisau circle does their best to
put him back together again the twisty
general angle tracks them down five
months later and as her troops storm the
resistances stolen u-boat blaskowitz
wakes up to shoot more Nazis
you might getting it back this first
mission sets the tone for the rest of
the new Colossus found to a wheelchair
his organs failing blaskowitz feels
oddly vulnerable you shoot with one hand
and slowly wheel yourself through the
u-boats corridors with the other the
odds seem impossible but overcoming them
is gratifying in a way that simply
killing all the Nazis can't match even
after the high-tech armor from the new
order gives blaskowitz his mobility back
his labored breathing reveals a man who
was running out of fuel and time on top
of that the game is just generally
difficult you'll probably die off in
defeating a giant fire-breathing robot
dog doesn't seem feasible at first but
it is with the right combination of
weapons strafing taking cover and
scrounging for health and ammo while on
the run part of that struggle is finding
a combat style that works for you and
sticking with it whether it's a guns
blazing or more tactical approach enemy
variety and multiple paths through any
given area means you'll be rewarded with
a thrilling fight regardless of how you
decide to tackle it you'll also be
rewarded with greater effectiveness in
combat at a steady pace successfully
executing a certain number of stealth
takedowns for example unlocks a perk
that increases your movement speed while
crouched and using upgrade parts you can
occasionally find lying around to say
put a silencer on your pistol will
further improve your stealth ability
but you're afforded the flexibility to
decide mid-mission that stealth is not
going to work and change tactics as a
result every encounter is incredibly
tense since you never know when you're
going to need to take it slow or book it
to safety as bullets fly by
[Music]
the far future technology of the Nazi
regime is both exhilarating to partaken
and a row test display of their ruthless
subjugation of all corners of the world
high-powered laser weapons are exciting
to use but the armored machine men who
dropped them are a reminder of human
experimentation during and after the war
anything is possible in Wolfenstein and
that's a direct result of immense human
suffering some particularly punishing
fights or a disadvantageous autosave can
be frustrating but most missions in just
before that frustration can turn to
anger aside from being a much-needed
break from fighting the story cutscenes
are beautifully directed and showcase
the series fantastic characters wait yes
streets are quiet each person on the
u-boat has their own story of oppression
and marginalization from the Black
Panthers to general angles anti-nazi
daughter even when the story goes
completely off the rails in an
absolutely jaw-dropping way there's
still room to explore their individual
dynamics and it balances the heavy
subject matter with a cheeky gung-ho
attitude that keeps you invested in the
crew and the cause anything
let's force more gays in there are times
when the new Colossus overreaches for
poignancy and as a result it states that
seems too overtly instead of letting
them stand alone some elements of
American patriotism like lines about
liberty and freedom feel misguided after
flashbacks that show the rampant racism
in the America Vijay's childhood and
while the arguments over the purpose of
the war and inspirational speeches about
fighting against impossible odds show
the breadth and depth of the resistance
movement for the most part these are
things you can discern just from playing
normally of course you should keep
fighting the Nazis even when it seems
pointless after all overcoming their and
stubble what might mission after mission
is satisfying enough on its own to keep
you going
again the main point here is killing
Nazis and no-questions-asked and the new
Colossus never lets you forget who and
why you're fighting Nazi brutality is on
full display from the blown out
irradiated remains of Manhattan to each
of the resistance members who all carry
mental scars if not physical ones
you're never given enough time between
cutscene missions and even downtime on
the u-boat to lose sight of the Reich's
cruelty Wolfenstein tense gameplay
elevates this further by giving you the
power to truly resist even when it all
seems hopeless
[Music]
[Music]